[Music]
paul lavity trained as a lawyer before
spending the mid-1980s in central
america investigating human rights
abuses
it was at this time that he approached
director ken loach with a screenplay
idea
the resulting romantic drama carla's
song marked the beginning of perhaps the
most successful writer-director
relationship in cinema
it is a prolific partnership yielding 10
films in a little over 15 years
these include my name is joe the wind
that shakes the barley and looking for
eric
paul's work is often political in nature
and seeks to explore perceived
injustices highlight forgotten
individuals and raise issues western
governments or societies are
uncomfortable with
it is this unwavering social conscience
that makes paul so significant as a
screenwriter
[Music]
you studied as a lawyer and in the 1980s
you were working
for a human rights organization in
nicaragua and i know in nicaragua and
other countries in in central central
america you experienced
at war at first hand why did you decide
to bring those experiences to cinema
specifically i just thought you know by
delving into fiction you can go into
another level you can really try and
there's just so many more levels to play
with
and then and in my instance i thought um
you'd be able to reach more people by
by
by cinema and a book sounded far too
difficult
i've talked to so many other writers and
read so many other articles about how
writers are marginalized they're not
included whereas i'm working with you
know with ken loach and he could not
treat a writer with more respect
you know so it'd be actually churlish to
say
that um
you know there should be more attention
to what i do because he's the most
generous of me i came back from
nicaragua i was there for three years
now central america i just wrote to ken
you know and then and he just wrote back
and said well you're passing by in
london you know popped in for a cup of
tea
and so i went to see him
and then he was remarkably curious they
didn't give a toss about whether i'd
written before and you know this film
industry which i didn't and he just said
we'll try and write a few scenes
and then he said this is a real long
shot
and then so the kind of the first half
of carla song kind of popped out
and then but there was a long time
between that and making it because ken
was working with a wonderful writer jim
allen and there were several projects in
front so we didn't get around to doing
it for about five years did you get in
touch because you felt from from from
knowing off him and from seeing his
films that you hoped you could you'd be
kindred spirits in some way yeah you
could share that yeah just i love the
films and you know i i knew what he was
what he had said and i'd read it found
out about it and then and so when i met
him he was just remarkably remarkably
curious and open
we took a little while to get going
and
in the meantime
ken and i were still making films with
other people so we did
when we first met paul um
we were doing
land and freedom and
ken had been very impressed by paul's
politics and decided to put him in land
and freedom he didn't do any writing for
it jim allen wrote down queen
but paul was a heavily highly
politicized scot
was just right for being in it
and that whole team is not and and not
just ken and rebecca though we're at the
hub of it i suppose a little film a
little company called 16 films and so we
feel like you're filmmakers first and
then we've all got different jobs and
then we meet together with different
skills
me as a screenwriter ken as a director
rebecca's a producer and then it spreads
out to the people we've been working
with for the last 15 years you know so
um
jonathan morris who's the editor george
fenton musician roger smith the script
editor so i feel like i'm surrounded by
you know first of all they're
marvelously talented people but secondly
they're and more importantly they're my
mates
so i'm i think i'm just incredibly
fortunate
they have a strong system going actually
of how they make films and they'll
generally be shooting one every two
years while ken's shooting a film paul
will probably be out there researching
the next one and having conversations
with him about the next one once ken's
back from shooting the one that uh that
he's about to go into the edit on funny
isn't it i mean people try to make it
very individualistic or the writer in
opposition to the director you know and
who is or whose idea is it you know and
try to nail it down as if we all do
separate things but it only works well
when you're working together
you know and when it does work together
it's absolutely marvelous and i've
fortunately had that experience because
i've worked with marvelously generous
people and there's never been a problem
with egos or ownership you know we're
we're faith it's like a football match
you know you're faithful to the team for
the last 15 years i mean since carla's
song was made you've written 12 13
features i think 10 of those have been
have made by um made by ken lodge carla
song was the first one the second one
was my name is joe in 1998.
[Music]
i mean there's a ticking bomb right from
the very beginning isn't there you know
my name is joe and i'm alcoholic and you
just go well what's going to happen to
him you know you know he's had a chaotic
past
you know he's probably he's had
blackouts and he's missed you know five
or six 10 15 20 years of his life
so now that he's sober those things have
got to come to the surface there's a lot
of things implied so you just feel that
a bomb ticking and also you feel like as
a man who's trying and you're on his
side you know and that's not a bad
option sometimes i think it's good to
have other characters where i mean there
have been other films like you know
sweet m it's a it's a free world where
the character is equal part repellent
and positive you know but in this
particular story i think you're kind of
rooting for him but you're suspecting
trouble and i think if you have that
tension at the beginning i think it can
be very very helpful would you say that
the glaswegian voice if you're writing
for the the character of joe for example
is the graduation voice the easiest one
for you to to tap into and run with when
you're writing when you're when you're
sitting there working on the script yeah
by a mile and i suppose i'm very lucky
too ken's always you know really been
supportive and helping with that i find
that you know because you know we've
made films in los angeles and nicaragua
and
and you know in other places
and you know i'm always just really
respectful of the differences with
people you know someone from mexico city
has got a different live view from you
know a campus you know in nicaragua
or you know someone who's grown up in
los angeles and so um they're all very
very different but so you have to work
much harder and listen you can never
capture it the same way but with
something from glasgow you just felt
it's your natural rhythm
he's just inventive and i love his use
of language particularly when he's
writing a scottish one
because that's his natural voice and
and
i come from scotland as well and so it's
it's like
it's joyous just to read the language
that paul writing the day i actually sat
down to start my name is joe i remember
the blank sheet i just remember the
absolute you know exhilaration
because i thought this man is going to
bring us to troublesome places and what
i loved about the character joe i mean
in my head before i started was there's
a one of the steps of of you know the
one of the 12 steps i think is the
fourth one he's got to make a fearless
moral inventory of himself
and there's great juice with that and
you so you don't know exactly where it
might go but you just feel he's going to
take you in on a on a journey and i kind
of love that kind of sense of excitement
i've not roughly you know not exactly
knowing where you're going to go
five year later
my second meeting shanks once again
dragged me to it five very very long
miserable years
i'm there
because i couldn't say i couldn't take
the note throughout that sentence
i couldn't say nine simple words my name
is joel and i'm an alcoholic
and there's a woman there that night
tiny tiny frail woman
who whispered whispered everything and
she said something that was so simple
she says i can no longer drink with
safety
and that really touched me even in the
state i was in and i was in a real
estate and she looked me right in the
eyeballs and she said remember you are
not alone
the way in which he sets about writing
of screenplay
is exemplary i mean what he does is he
you know an idea will bubble to the
surface between ken and paul and
and
between us we all decide well this is
the one we're going to follow this is
the the road we should go along for the
next film
you know we're often sending each other
articles back and forward one day i
remember we actually sent two articles
to each other identical articles by
total
accident you know
so there must be kind of some
[Music]
um
symbiotic kind of
manner of working otherwise things like
that just you know wouldn't work
paul then
will go off and spend six or nine months
reading and researching and and finding
out about
the ideas and just
making sure that
he's done all the homework and i think
that's a really important thing for
writers to do to do the homework i do
listen and talk to an awful lot of
people i think listening for a writer is
greatly underestimated i think it's
great underestimated for a human being
and but it's you know people are happy
to talk about their lives and and the
great thing about it i suppose you're
doing a screenplay isn't it you're just
trying to understand the world from
someone else's point of view
you know and
you know you only see the world from
your point of view so to try and
understand it just by listening to
people just gives you great information
and gives you new ideas so i don't think
you can copy a screenplay from the
street you can't do that but it really
gives you a lot more information a lot
more ideas you know if you're talking to
a kid or someone from a different
culture a different language or
different sex or who is much older much
younger different country have just seen
the world a different way and when you
listen and talk to them
sometimes it's absolutely remarkable if
i remember when we did bread and roses
you know it was shot in los angeles it
was about immigrant workers coming up
from central america there were women
spoke spanish meant subtitles it was
about trade union organizing because um
they were massively abused and there was
a justice for janitor's campaign and i
met these people and i worked with them
and they were brilliant and absolutely
fascinating of course nobody else in the
entire world
of filmmaking finance wanted to make a
film with women who are not well known
who are immigrants who didn't speak
english you know so for a film like that
you've got to fight very very hard but
never for one single second did i think
ken was not shoulder to shoulder with me
it wasn't even discussed i remember
rebecca o'brien the producer when she
went to cannes in preparation
she came with more money than she left
with you know it was as bad as that
there's a
one scene that comes to mind in paul
lavitty's work there's a particular
scene in bread and roses which he made
with ken loach in 2000 they went out to
california to make this film in los
angeles about immigrant mexican workers
in the city and it focuses on two
sisters one of whom who's newer to the
city than her sister who's been settled
there longer she's older and the younger
sister confronts the older sister
because she thinks that she's
essentially betrayed her sister and her
fellow workers at the cleaning company
at which they work by by giving some
information to a manager
that
[Music]
i loved how ken dealt with this scene
because um
because it's all coming from the older
sister
so
he didn't give
maya
the script at all
all that she knew was that she'd
betrayed in the first line you know why
did you do it
and then so
that was her hearing for the you know
the the first time the writing is
brilliant this is explores really gray
areas between the two of them we enter
the scene
on the side of the younger sister and we
come out of it understanding both of
them completely i think that's something
that paul does does very well he upends
our expectations of where he thinks
well where we think the film is going to
take us but it was amazing dave going to
tijuana and
juarez and all these places along the
border we have all these maquila
factories
and you know what was remarkable about
them was we actually go to the factories
the factories are state of the art i
went to see one afford they were making
beautiful breaks and machines and all
that then i met some of the organizers
and you know grassroots organizers of
the people so i went to see where they
lived and you know the pallets the
wooden pallets that brought in all this
fancy machinery that's what they lived
in and they were working so many hours
their children were just left
you know just to wonder
i mean it's an experiment of absolute
just totally unrelated brutal capitalism
because you just they just work and then
they're just dumped and there's no
infrastructure there's absolutely
nothing so there's no surprise in a way
that one aberration breeds another and
whereas you know like i don't know how
many thousands of women literally are
murdered each year along the juarez
border and then a lot of them drifted
they can't they can't they actually
they're working so hard and doing double
shifts so the weekends they often go
crazy
they go drinking and then often because
they're not money they drift into
prostitution so after seeing all that
and talking to these people and seeing
the faces and seeing where they went
then you have the the confidence perhaps
you know to to try and write that and
give your voice i think there's a touch
of uh you might not like me saying this
but it's definitely touching the
journalists to paul i mean he wants to
get out there he wants to meet people he
wants to talk to people he wants to
research stories that's not to say he
then
copies that or just brings characters
he's met on the street into his films
but he uses all that
to inform the stories that he writes you
have to find something that's massively
fresh to me that you kind of dive into
and also just
captures your curiosity you know you're
asking someone to dedicate the best part
of two years or often more of their life
to that project so you have to ask
yourself the toughest question of like
you know why why this one
you know quite apart from all the
difficulties if you could manage or pull
it off or find interesting characters or
a premise but you know why this material
and i'm also aware that you know ken has
been making films for many many years
before me you know and so he's covered a
lot more stuff and you know sometimes
i've been fascinated by something he
goes well maybe touched upon that and
another one you go yeah of course we try
not to do the film we just did we try
not to do them
so
it's what's concerning us it's we want
to do films that
that
describe our lives or or that tackle
things that concern us as
people
and
you know about the world of work or the
world of
you know
i suppose you've seen injustice and you
think
it would be great to see
that exposed
but it's more about
trying to find different angles trying
to find unusual angles to go at things
from is it important to you that your
your characters
are constantly contradicting themselves
they're surprising us as an audience but
surprising you as a writer as well as
you take them through a story i'm glad
you asked that that great that asked
that question is really really important
to to all of us you know 16 films
because it is it's at the heart i think
of what we're trying to achieve you know
because we are often achieved accused of
being
propagandistic
and then
we're
and we don't see the world in simple
terms at all
you know i mean i love that phrase from
oscar wilde you know the truth is um
is is is never is never simple and
seldom pure the other way around but
anyways that's mixed up you know and
that's the beauty about drama you can
dive into that and so catching those
contradictions
and the characters
are the are the things that we're always
looking for and by far the most
important and i think the more
complicated things are the more
interesting they are because that's the
way life is it's not simple
it's a free world i think is a good
example of that what we didn't want to
do was tell that story from the point of
view of the immigrant worker because
that was too obvious and to to try and
twist it around and to do the story
of the woman who
was actually
i know
bringing them in and and
and lashing the whip you know that
is a much more interesting person to
explore
because you know what to her concerns
what's what's
what makes her tick why is she so cruel
you know
why is she so vindictive and then
and and that's and that's much more
interesting and when things are left
dangling because there are no simple
answers you know where you live your
class your education who your parents
are it's complicated and difficult you
know and different for every single
person but what is obviously clear is
the circumstances in which you live the
world of your story
you know impinges upon us i mean
all you have to be surrounded by
beautiful architecture and just how you
feel you know you feel different you
know and if you're in a different
circumstance what does that do to you
you know i look at joe joe only works
because of his limited choices our young
liam and sweet sixteen so it's a key
question for us when we're when we're
planning a story is like you know
where are they at what point and we have
to be consistent and realistic to the
circumstances which impinge on those
characters lives and hopefully if you do
that well for that particular individual
as a ripple effect and you try to
understand how they came to be that
person
i think there's so many stereotypes and
and misunderstandings because
you know
you know good issues don't make for good
films you've you know
there's fantastically wonderful
issues around the world but you know
cinema cinema's got to be more that
story's got to be more than that it's
got to be a great story first
and that's always the challenge you know
and um
so that's that's quirky it's not
something you can
just measure or do it's kind of
it's not something you learn
i think it's something you just
instinctively kind of
go for and sometimes you you might catch
something that's
that just kind of resonates in a way
that you might not have expected when
you when you when you make it and
sometimes you think a film is going to
go much better than it actually does but
doesn't resonate in the same way you
might imagine because you actually start
the process off when the film comes out
sometimes there's two three many more
years i think bread and roses were six
even the rain was over 10. you know i
mean so things chop and change
[Applause]
or
[Music]
is
is
[Applause]
[Music]
this film was dedicated to the memory of
a wonderful friend howard zinn who
helped me with the historical research
who died two months before the film was
finished and if you ever
feel like a fantastic read he wrote the
people's history of the united states
absolutely brilliant book and he was a
wonderful wonderful man so i'm gonna see
this piece always always reminds me of
him he was an absolutely brilliant story
and had a massive effect in many
historians
and he asked me after after having seen
bread and roses if i had prepared to
write a script inspired by the first
chapter
of his book which is the rival of
columbus this iconic figure what was set
in motion by that
the first place of conscience and indian
resistance which i did but did you feel
when you were first trying to write that
film as a historical drama did you feel
that the more honest thing for you to do
was was to pull back and bring the bring
the filmmaking process into the actual
story yes it was it was a device really
because i'm not interested really about
films about making films there was a way
for us to have lots of angles on what
happened 500 years ago actors challenge
other actors about you know what the
role was and and it challenges the whole
notion of objectivity and history as
well i think because by the mere fact of
selection you know there is no
objectivity you know you make a choice
about who your protagonists and
characters are so i think there's a
great nonsense talked about objectivity
and we try to play with that too and
then but there was one bit of material
that kept me going you know when i
thought we'd lost it you know because i
spent so much time doing the history
doing the historical piece i was never
happy with it but there was this first
letter from columbus back
to the king and queen of spain which is
the first report back from the new world
to the old world and he said with just
50 men we could subjugate them and make
them do what we want this was after
taking their food and saying they were
very gentle and then he wanted to say
something that was really really
remarkable i think he said you know
right at the very end of the letter they
said souls for christ
and much profit and i think it's
fascinating how we always look you know
for justification for making profit you
know we've changed
in 500 years but not that much the
psychology of that first letter was
wonderful i think today it's you know um
modernization and much profit it's
privatization and much profit but they
always need that moral obligation in
which to exploit people and i think in a
strange way that metaphorical 50 men
that tiny elite i mean look at the roots
of this crisis with the financial sector
and united states how they lobbied and
put pressure to deregulate so they could
make a fortune and i think that
metaphorical 50 people are still trying
to subjugate us and make us do what we
want and so it's interesting reading the
history 500 years ago and all that's
going through your head when you see
this whole thing well i think for all
the you know the heavy research element
and even journalistic elements of paul's
work he does in the end make you know
human dramas most of them fictional
maybe based on things he's
things he's seen or people he's met i
mean i think he is actually interested
in crafting crafting fiction and finding
the emotional core of the stories that
he's telling so i think that's why drama
suits him more than documentaries would
he's unashamedly
uh
good at writing
sort of description
beautifully i think i also also feel
that with paul's work he feels that that
there's a correction to be made in terms
of what other films are saying or what
other films aren't even daring to say
about the world and and by by telling
those stories on film and by bringing
those stories to cinema he feels they
can bring them you know to a wider
audience uh and to an audience that may
be seeing another side of the story from
other cinema or maybe not seeing any
story of that sort at all
he's brilliantly inventive
he's very funny
he always surprises me with
the way he'll take a plot he'll throw in
a twist that you just don't expect would
you say that comedy and humor is
important to all your scripts really
because i think even even in your darker
work there's always moments of humor
there's all there are always moments of
comedy
i mean this is something that me and ken
feel very strongly about i suppose
um
i mean
everywhere you go when i went to juarez
or i went to nicaragua during the during
the war or el salvador and very
miserable dark time just you meet people
with great spirits you know they're
going around miserable all the time i
mean i think humor is a way of coping as
well but it's also very much a part of
us and i think humor is a way that you
you know it's one thing you do if you
mean if you are powerless you can laugh
and take the piss and undermine you know
and i think that's i mean
laughter i suppose is wit you know and
people use that as to defend themselves
as well and it's part of us it's a
beautiful part of us i think you know
a lot of the times making films there's
confusion really you know you just don't
know exactly what's going to come up but
you do have to follow your instinct you
know like eric cantona was a wonderful
surprise you know you wouldn't imagine
building a film around eddie cantona he
actually came to us
and he came to us with a real story
about a fan who followed him from leeds
so absolutely nothing to do with the
film
but you know when eric appeared and were
both football fans and he had such kind
of panache and he was such a kind of a
character
it really
helped me
um
make a film always wanted to make a big
grandparents which probably nobody else
would have been interested in i was kind
of fascinated with families break up now
you know and you know you're looking
after other people's kids and
you know other people looking after your
kids and poor old eric at this point in
time
he's just fallen through his own fingers
they feel he's got no identity nobody
listens to him and then he just feels
he's literally falling apart and has
absolutely
no control
of his life so he can have a needsa he
needs a friend i think and then he has
an imaginary relationship with probably
someone on the pitch
who had probably more confidence than
anyone ever in the history of football
and so i love the idea of throwing these
two things together you know ken loved
the idea eric loved that idea and so we
went for it but it was
so you've got to improvise you can't
have like five year plans you know it
was something that
it was a lovely little present eric
cantona was um
would you say an unlikely but a welcome
collaborator oh he was great it was
great fun and he was also very modest
and very smart and you know
he'd seen a lot of ken's films and
really wanted to work with him he came
with a different idea very very
different from this about a lead
supporter who had followed him we were
both kind of fascinated we loved both
loved football
and
and
he was a gem and we just thought it
would maybe take us to
another way of telling the story
you must say no
no
come on say it
no
in french
no
no
like you mean it
no
no
more more
no
no
no no
from your balls
no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
no no no no
[Music]
dad
are you all right
no
i'm often asked to do um
these master classes and it always makes
me laugh really because
you know master class sounds like you
know you really know what you're doing
and you're a master i mean to me is like
somebody who really knows how to do
karate or a mask master cook you know
what so i don't really feel i know how
to write scripts when you're so steeped
in the mysterio the material it's very
very hard to be a do objective but
that's again the great thing about
working on a team and bringing in
friends and and talking about it
and
you know and trying to see how you can
just make it work better and it's
endlessly kind of complex and sometimes
you're confused but again just if you're
working with a great team it's
you you feel you just do your best and
then it's in the lap of the gods and be
fearless about it
[Music]
so
[Music]
you